-Republicans passed a sweeping
overhaul of the tax code
that will overwhelming benefit
corporations and the wealthy,
amounting to nothing left than
a brazen heist of the country.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump
keeps his insisting,
despite all evidence
to the contrary,
that this tax bill
will not be a boon
to the richest Americans.
In fact, in the spirit
of the holiday season,
he keeps calling it a Christmas
gift to the middle class.
-This is gonna be
one of the great gifts
to the middle-income people
of this country
that they've ever gotten
for Christmas.
It will be the greatest
Christmas present
that a lot of people
have ever received.
We're now one
huge step closer to delivering
to the American people
the historic tax relief
as a giant present
for Christmas.
Remember I said
we're bringing Christmas back?
Christmas is back,
bigger and better
than ever before.
We're bringing Christmas back.
-It almost sounds like
he was about to start singing.
[ Laughter ]
It's like he's doing
a Weird Al cover
of a Justin Timberlake song.
"I'm bringing Christmas back.
Them other holidays
are super whack."
[ Laughter ]
Also,
Christmas didn't go anywhere.
We're all up to our necks
in Christmas.
Every TV show
has a Christmas episode.
Every commercial
has a Christmas song.
There's a 70-foot tree
outside my office window,
and every barista in town
is wearing antlers.
If you want to bring
something back, try Kwanzaa.
That thing
straight-up disappeared.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, virtually every
reputable study of the tax bill
says the corporations
and the wealthy will benefit
far more than anyone else.
For one thing, the corporate
tax cuts are permanent,
while the individual
tax cuts expire,
which means that by 2027,
more than 80% of the plan's
benefits go to the top 1%
while 53% of taxpayers
will see a tax hike.
And if you just
look at next year,
the plan's benefits
are very heavily skewed
towards the wealthy.
Middle-income taxpayers
would pay about $900 less
where the highest-income
1% of households
would get an average tax cut
of roughly $50,000.
Here's what that means
in real terms.
So, to recap,
if you're rich,
you're getting
a car for Christmas,
and if you're not, go ahead
and wrap up a can of gas.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course, Republicans --
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna set this
next to the fire
and open it later.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, Republicans can't
point to any actual proof
their plan would benefit lower-
and middle-income people,
so all they can do
is repeat vague talking points
about improving the economy.
For example, Ivanka Trump,
the President's daughter
and adviser,
tweeted this week...
Prompting a response
from her father, who wrote...
Man, that's got to suck
for Eric and Don Jr.
They tweet about their dad
all the time...
[ Laughter ]
...and all they ever get
is a broken upside-down heart.
[ Laughter ]
"What's the button
for hate them?"
[ Laughter ]
And yet despite the overwhelming
evidence to the contrary,
Trump has repeatedly claimed
not just that the wealthy,
in general,
would be hurt by the bill,
but that he personally
would pay more in taxes
than he did before.
-We're also going to eliminate
tax breaks and complex loopholes
taken advantage of
by the wealthy.
Who are they?
I don't...
[ Laughter ]
I think my accountants
are going crazy right now.
It's all right.
Hey, look, I'm President.
I don't care.
I don't care anymore.
-We definitely believe
that you don't care.
[ Laughter ]
You're, by far,
our most checked-out President.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, James Garfield
worked harder than you
after he was assassinated.
[ Laughter ]
You watch more TV than a
6th-grader at home with the flu.
Trump watches so much TV,
we're like a week away
from him tweeting
about "The Price is Right."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, obviously,
we can't know exactly
how Trump would benefit
from this bill,
since he still refuses
to release his tax returns.
But we do know
there are lots of changes
that would impact him directly.
For one thing,
Republicans lowered
the top income-tax bracket.
There are also tax breaks
for so-called
pass-through businesses, which
includes the Trump organization.
There was even
a last-minute provision added
that specifically extends
a new tax break
for pass-through businesses
to real-estate investors.
In fact, the bill
has so many complicated
tax breaks and giveaways,
Republicans are trying to argue
that average Americans
would benefit
from those tax breaks
by really stretching the meaning
of the word "average."
Take this tweet yesterday
from Texas Senator John Cornyn.
Cornyn wrote...
Yeah, you know,
that average American family
that has two kids, a house,
a white picket fence,
corporate income,
noncorporate business income,
three limited-liability
corporations,
two S corporations,
two C corporations,
a commercial
real-estate venture,
a limited-liability partnership,
carried interest,
oh, and a dog.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Average.
You know, average.
In fact, this bill doesn't even
deliver on the flimsy pretext
Republicans initially gave
for their tax plan --
simplifying the tax code.
For example, the plan keeps
seven different tax brackets
rather than the three
Republicans initially proposed.
Former GOP presidential
candidate Herman Cain
proposed his own tax-code
simplification plan,
called the 9-9-9 plan,
was asked about that failure
on Fox News
and didn't seem too troubled.
-Your plan had 9-9-9.
This one
still has seven brackets.
It may not be
as simple as you wanted,
but is it a big win
for Republicans?
-It's not 9-9-9-,
but it's fine, fine, fine.
-Look how happy Herman Cain is.
He can't believe
they set him up for a rhyme.
His public life is done.
Now he'll just disappear,
never to be seen again.
No, Herman, don't go!
What will we do without you?!
-Don't worry.
You'll be fine, fine, fine.
[ Laughter ]
-And on top of everything else,
this bill also adds nearly
$1.5 trillion to the deficit
after years of GOP hysteria
about government spending,
and Republicans
are already being very open
about the fact
that they're going to use
the deficits they created
as an excuse to cut
Social Security, Medicare,
and Medicaid
under the guise
of so-called welfare reform.
Last week, House Speaker
Paul Ryan, a father of three,
was asked about
paying for those programs
and said the problem wasn't that
Republicans are giving away
billions to corporations
and the wealthy
but that people
aren't having enough babies.
-The great thing about
tax reform coming right now
is we're gonna be able
to create the kind of an economy
that produces good,
family-supporting jobs,
higher wages that
will be there for people
who are stuck in poverty
and welfare to go to.
This is going to be the new
economic challenge for America.
People.
Baby boomers are retiring.
I did my part, but we need
to have higher birth rates
in this country.
-I'm sorry.
You did you your part?
You know who might have
something to say about that?
Your wife.
If I had turned to my wife
right after my son was born
and said,
"Well, I did my part,"
I'm pretty sure,
she would've picked me up
and broken me over her knee
like Bane.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It tells you everything you need
to know about the Trump era
if this is how 2017 is ending,
with Republicans
ransacking the country,
taking healthcare
away from millions,
and then telling women
that the solution is for them
to have more babies.
Working and middle-class people
overwhelmingly
dislike this bill.
Meanwhile,
corporations and the wealthy
are looking at it
and saying it's...
-Fine, fine, fine.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]